you would know that cuz you a doctor
yeah well doctorate degree in physical
physical uh therapy physical therapy so
um yeah that's my education but I mean
I'm I'm not even I haven't practiced in
10 years but I did get my license
reinstated um during the pandemic so I'm
good dude I I heard you say that you
spent nine years uh in medical training
or medical school no no no I I went to
college and then four years of
graduate program and then a year and a
half of like a residency program okay so
n years of post high school [__] oh yeah
no I went to school consistently from
the time I was 5 till 27 every single
year I was in school and you did The
Residency where you go in and actually
yep yeah in New York yeah um for pH for
physical therapy not like an actual
doctor not like an ER no no no no no
physical therapy massaging elbows I'm
good at that what made you choose that
profession I wanted to not ever work in
like a cubicle or anything like that I
didn't never want to be like a person in
like a sea of cubicles and my you know
my mom like never liked her job and I
would you know single mom I would hear
her hating her job all the time she like
I just sit in this cubicle I hate it you
know and I was like all right I don't
want to do that so then I wanted to work
with kids so I became a pediatric
physical therapist and um and then I
started comedy in my first year of
physical therapy school so or last year
physical therapy school so I quickly you
know I was only physical therapist for
like 2 3 years but that initially was I
was like I want to cuz you know you work
with adults and then they they're not
grateful at all like you'll you know
like they just you know they take for
granted because we get like you know we
get older and we get we forget like to
have to be gratuitous to things and then
but when you work with kids especially
disabled kids I mean dude their families
I mean all these kids they're all in
wheelchairs they have cereal paly and
this and that and just to get them to
like stand up or take a step it's like a
Monumental task and I'm like that this
feels better than you know massaging
someone's Pinky and then them you know
calling me a piece of [__] cuz I messed
one [__] thing up you know yeah D
it's so interesting because um the the
one human who I've known for the longest
time my buddy Abdullah we've known each
other since we were 9 years old we
graduated high school together um I went
on to do what I went on to do but
Abdullah went to Brown University
graduated with a 4.0 went on to Cornell
Medical School then became a pediatric
surgeon at the Mayo Clinic and has since
developed methods of uh operating on
unborn babies in the womb and and and
his whole rationality is the same thing
he does not want to work on adults like
he's almost disgusted by him maybe I'm
putting those words in his mouth but I
he's disgusted with adults and only
wants to help children because they have
innocence yeah he he was saying that
like he goes into the womb he opens up
you know all the the amniotic sack and
then does an operation on the baby
fetus's spine fuses it together sews the
baby up and then sews the sack back what
look at all that look at out all that
genius all that smart and and he's just
known as sto's
friend Abdullah Abdullah Abdullah abdah
we should get him on the podcast he's
he's the best man he's absolutely the
best and I want to take a moment to be
serious and say that I think you're the
best dude W like I I really like like we
we don't know each other did we ever do
comedy like in the in the round together
during the pandemic no maybe once or
twice but never never spoke right okay
yeah yeah and um you know I think what
what uh I forget who who reached out to
who sooner but I think you hit me up at
dude I saw that clip of uh you and Bert
where you're so emotional about how you
know you probably hear about it all the
time but I mean dudee like it's just man
I fell in love with you on that oh
thanks yeah that and that wasn't you
know some people like after that clip
came out they were like oh you staged
that I was like no I me and ber were
having a great time talking about just
comedy and then I don't know what the
hell happened but we started talking
about our kids and then I started to
have like this Epiphany live on his show
about like how much time I'm missing in
my kids's life to pursue this and I'm
like I don't want to do that and know
right the way that the clip played out
you said you said to Bert you know dude
I'm killing it and you know comedy's
going so well I'm touring I'm making
tons of money but at the cost of not
seeing my kids grow up you said that I'm
watching my daughters grow up through a
iPhone screen like and and you started
to cry and like it was kind of a bad
look for Bert If we're honest because
he's just sort of like laughing at you
like laughing at you not even
understanding like any importance
whatsoever for watching your children
grow up yeah yeah well then he goes he
goes you know I'm going to do that too
after that and then immediately like
within I swear to God like 24 hours of
that episode airing he announced a world
tour I mean and bless bird I love him to
death man I love him to death but it was
just so endearing and then when uh you
and I started communicating about uh
doing each other's podcasts you know we
started texting like you don't see that
in this day age like people like
responding so quickly to a text message
and writing such like thoughtful fully
formed sentences right you know I'm like
wow dude this guy Chris is so thoughtful
so
uh kind and generous you know well you
know what I think that I think that I
with
comedy or some of my peers you know that
I came up with you know the mark
Norman's the Sam morals those guys those
was like my comedy class in New York and
those guys are true they know everything
about comedy comedy historians they know
it and they respect the art form and
it's beautiful thing to see where I just
came from I only started comedy for two
reasons the only things I ever wanted to
do was one make a sitcom show about my
dad and about the relationship I have
with my dad and second do comedy at
Madison Square Garden that's the only
things I that those are my only goals I
I didn't I was never like I got to be
the best and I'm going to I never cared
about all that stuff was always so
like superflous to me CU I was like
Alexander the Great conquered the whole
world nobody gives a [__] like it's all
our own egos that create that create
this pump and Circumstance about
ourselves like none of it's real so I
was just like what do I want to do and
those are the only two things that I
wanted to do so for me when I like you
know like you was always such a fan of
yours I was like oh when you like I
you'll do we'll do this podcast and then
we'll turn around and do my podcast cuz
I know it's a business I was like no
dude I just want to do you I want to
I'll give my energy for you I don't care
if I monetize it with [__] hellofresh
who gives a [__] it wasn't ju as a
byproduct of my gold chasing I get to
meet cool people and I'm like whether we
monetize that or not I I don't care do
you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is sto's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get sto's hot sauce for your butthole
plus sto's butthole destroyer and steo
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right
now yeah dude